All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar,
everyone. Before we introduce our speaker,
let's go for some rules as usual. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk. If you have
immediate questions, you're welcome to unmute
and ask. Otherwise, please use the chat room
to post your questions so that we can address
them in the q&a session at the end. So again,
today's seminar is open to external audience,
so no classified discussion is allowed. Finally,
the talk will be recorded and uploaded to our
YouTube channel. Now, let me introduce our
speaker. It is an honor to your host Professor
Kwanlin, who is currently a full professor in
the Department of Mathematics and the School of
Mechanical Engineering at Purdue University. He
is the director of data science consulting
service that performs cutting edge research
on data science and provides hands on consulting
support for data analysis and business analytics.
He is also the chair of the initiative for
data science and engineering applications
at College of Engineering. He received
his PhD from Brown University in 2007.
And work as a research scientist at
Pacific Northwest Northwest National
Laboratory before joining Purdue in
2014. He has received various awards,
such as the NSF career award, miss me, Korea,
sigma c award, university faculty scholar,
College of Science Research Award mathmatical Bow
Bow SANS Institute earlier Early Career Award. And
so today he will talk about tomorrow's first wave
AI in interpretable, robust, trustworthy machine
learning for diverse applications in science and
engineering. Please enjoy the wonderful talk. Now,
without further ado, let me hand it over to
Professor Lin. Okay, yeah. Hello, everyone.
Thanks for coming to my webinar. So today I will
talk about focus on robust and interoperable Trust
works in machine learning. So the difference from
other people, so we're doing is basically to be
able to quantify the uncertainty in the machine,
and it's in particular deep learning. So like
this, this unary structure I want to show you so
we are able to make prediction, instead of just
one, like the prediction, we are predicted the
mean prediction, also the uncertainty as well.
You can say, Oh, the police have two channels. So
that's the first reveal the fall wave of AI. So,
it contains four different waves. So, this is
basically so the designed by the data, right?
So they have the three wave of AI. So the first
is from 70 to 90 days, right. So, the application
is like in the chess, right. And the second wave
from 2000 to present, while typical is autonomous
driving and also the half ago. And then the third
way is from 2020 to 30. That is a week's patch at
perceiving learning and reasoning. So
similar to like jtbd. And the first way
we are hoping this beyond the 2030 that's able
to perform any intelligent task than a human be.
So So let's look at some possible applications.
One is using AI for image coloring, you know,
consider we have a lot of 100 years
pictures, and we can use AI to you know,
coloring them to make them become colorful
pictures, there's the one application and
the other one is talking about is
AlphaGo using the reverse learning
to play chess, this is from the DeepMind pictures.
So this is artificial intelligence on autonomous
driving. So for example, yeah, as long as we
can get the the camera in front of vehicles,
so we can capture the road conditions
then we can use into to the control.
Okay, so the following we can look into like
microbe the main researcher direction is
considered as a five directions. So one is focus
on integral by AI. The goal is try to discover of
the physical law from the noisy data. And the
second direction I want to do is the UK as a
qualification for the reliable AI. And the third
direction I'm working on is the privacy preserving
AI for learning from the distributed sensitive
data. And another one I'm focused on to the AI
for science and engineering. In particular,
I'm doing AI for material discovery. And also
on the educational side. I was doing the AI for
workforce development. So I have the rapid preview
As the impact data science education program to
utilize the AI tool to help
us to do the no education.
So on every side, so we have developed
various version of the neural network,
why is we can take the multi fidelity data to the
other neural network that can take the money today
the information to make a better prediction. The
second is we want to take the physical loss and
the equations into our AI so that our
prediction can satisfy the equations,
the paper loss. So therefore, on
the right hand side, in this box,
we have these PDE loss functions, so that they
can minimize to change the neural network.
So I'm here I'm doing is we're developing these
so called linear operators, the idea is that we
want our input to independent of the resolution
in time and the space. So we can input the input
as like a different resolution of the image,
or different resolution of the time series
as inputs, we can make predictions,
no matter of the input resolution.
Traditional neural network is very limited
by the number of image if the tutor nearby
to figure six times to finish second, it has
to be the same size. Right. The last one we're
working on is so called the February top rated
learning. So that particular use for if the data
is sensitive, such as like a hospital patient
data, so you don't want to share between the
hospital then disciplinary operate learning will
be very important for such kind of application.
So in particular, is his outline my talk so,
I will introduce how to incorporate physical
knowledge and AI to design new interpretable
models that we'll talk about for multiscale
modeling how we incorporate physical knowledge
into AI. And now we'll talk about you know,
Interpro AI, how to develop a personalized the
treatment for Alzheimer's disease prediction. And
also, we'll talk about sparse neural architecture
design with quantify the uncertainty. Finally,
I will talk about the scalable chaining large
scale deep neural network in particular, so,
first I will talk about incorporate physical
knowledge and AI to design new intergral model.
So, the focus is tried to do the integral AI for
science. So, we have two publications. So, you can
say one is at the nature of computational science,
and the other it's a past competition about
both about the use of AI to do a model for
communicating prediction. So, let's look at
how we do that. So, first of all, we develop
a framework that basically a framework build a
trustworthy data driven epidemiology model. So,
the idea is we take the data right and also the
events happening then based on the data, we
develop a model and the different from other
people we do identifiability analysis, so that
way on the on the OD level, we want to evaluate
whether you know, on the parameters inside these
od model whether they are identified or not. So,
if it is not then we have to go back to the
design model again, if yes, we go to next tab
to do the sensitivity analysis. So, from there,
we know which parameters are important then we
go to the model calibration to calibrate
to the important parameters, then the next
step we want to do is so called the model robust
analysis, the idea is what if the data is nice,
right, I want to make sure my prediction is
you know, robust with respect to the noise.
If the yes then I can use it to the
forecast that is uncertainty. Otherwise,
I have to go back to the model design again,
also the slope. So, this is the basically the
firmware developed is basically a general
framework presents a work file, you know,
most of the day deployment models,
the ultimate. So, here I want to use
in your city as an example. So, as we know,
we use New York City. We all know that this
blue line represents a different events
timeline that's happening in New York City. So,
this blue curve represented this
number of daily cases of COVID-19.
So the horizontal is the timeframe from you
know, February 2020 to the end of the 2020.
You can see the events from the stay at home
order to mask the mandate to endow tiny reopen to
vaccination. Okay, so this is
all the events. So this is all
the data we have. So we tried to
get the data and build a model.
So here's the data we normally collected. So
on the A is represent the number of daily case,
the B is the number of daily hospitalization, the
C is the number of the data they need as the D is
the vaccine. So the light blue is the dose one,
the dark blue is those two. Okay, so you can say,
this is the data we have and we want to based
on this data. So here's a, you know, extended
version of the epidemiology model. So traditional
called SR model is ER model, but we expanded it so
that it can incorporate the particular for the
COVID-19. So you can say the basically is a od
systems right in the system. So basically this
because susceptible exposed, right? I mean, so.
impulse to, to the COVID-19 edge means the
hospitalization hospital, the D means desk,
humans quarantine, Arby's recover, okay? The aim
is ASIC medic, and the does a little reservoir
here that is the vaccine, basically where you
you have you take the vaccine, then they can
take you directly to the recover, you don't
need to go through the hospitalization step.
Okay, so this is a
model we developed the there's some parameters
are very important that we need to using the
data to help us so one of those codes of beta
was the transmission rate, and the P and Q are
the hospitalization the death rate. So, so, here
we treat all these parameters as stepwise constant
parameter using the data we try to categorize
them. So this is a this is the after calibration,
we are able to calibrate the parameter with
respect to the each events. So our assumption
is that after each events, this constant will
change because of this Niaga. City Policy.
So here is we are using this model to make
three different scenario evaluation. So for
New York City, they want to reopen the dining at
February 14. Yeah, we all know why is February 14,
because it's a one enticed day. So you want
to open the indoor dining on February 14. So
therefore, we use our model make three different
scenarios to analyze the number of infected cases.
On the left, we assume that they just
don't have the indoor dining at all,
they don't put it all there. In the middle
column, we say we reopened in our dining on
the February 14 On the right, we say How about
we delay this opening out and one month later
to the March 14. Okay. So therefore, we have
three different kinds of predictions. So the
first row represents some data cases, the middle
row means the number of daily hospitalization,
then the last row is number of deaths.
Okay. So, by doing that, we can run three
different scenarios, and we can predict the
number of cases with insanely error bars,
then we can use this to provided the New York
City government and say, so, here's the you know,
the prediction based on the model right, so that
they can make a decision based on this data driven
prediction. So, this is one of the forecasts
that we recently sent the other scenarios.
The last one I want to show you is we also do have
a so called physical environment your network. So,
the idea is that we want to develop a
flexible campaign to to to start a model
essence aid and also incorporate data and the
different models, so that we can you know,
accurate feeding to the data and infer model
parameter and that discovered the episode physics.
So, by doing that, we develop you know,
a family of epidemiology model. So,
that include the integer the model from simple
to complex, and also the fracture order model
and the time delay model from simple to complex.
So, the idea is we want to identify which model
is most appropriate in making the prediction and
also we want to account for the memory effect.
So, the idea of this fiscal inform the owner
for the fractional epidemiology model, so,
the idea is want to develop a neural network
for the prediction of our state variable you
and for the model parameter beta p q k, also we
model them as a time dependent parameter as well.
Then all these parameters and variables
ever satisfy our od E. So, therefore,
in the last function, we had to defy the
first terms on the ride so called data loss,
basically want to know the discrepancy between
now prediction versus the data you collect
then we do our two now, and the other
so called od loss or the residual loss,
the idea is want to say, okay, the really
just supposed to be zero right, but
we build this in you're now we're plugging in
back into the equation want to check what's in
religion want to minimize them so, therefore, we
added this od loss so, we want to in the total
loss of one combine the data loss and the OD
loss together do the minimization and hopefully
this developed your Namco will be able to have
you know very small d loss and also very small
od loss so that it says fie the OD equations
in the meantime you satisfy the previous data
now, here's a peek at the data. So, on the left
we present the year we can feed in the data
accurately for the variable that we
have the observation on the right
basically on the in the middle,
we begin showing you we ask and
discover the opposite of the dynamics.
But because there's no ground truth, so,
we are able to predict a different kind of
outputs of the observer dynamics using given
the model on the right is basically we infer the
model parameters based on the different models.
So, here I want to introduce a little bit
about the fracture other models right,
because this model can help us to
introduce the memory in the dynamics. So,
here is a so called the Kabuto directive
this a copper represented fraction order. So,
the copper normally speaking the only one so, it
basically is integral differential equations, so,
you can say. So, the idea is that this
one can describe the memory effect. So,
let's look at we assume our capa will be will
not be a constant will be a function of time.
So, so therefore, that parameter will be
highly depends on, you know, the data,
we can use in data to determine
what's the friction now there is.
So let's look at the friction order
versus the integral rather. So if
kappa less than one, right you can have a decay
factor versus the integer. So the sorry lines
need the integer model and the dashed line is
the fraction of model right so you can say the
delay effect can be described by the functional
model. Similar things for other variables too.
So here's a quick summary. So but here
we develop a data driven framework that
can be integrated. The tools help us
to quantify that certainties. And also,
we directed the COVID-19 model right and also
physically inform you now to study the model s&t.
So the next step I want to show you
is the physical knowledge input into
the AI to pretty much get a problem.
So we call the neuro homogenization.
So this is joint work, okay with some my postdoc
and my collaborator. So this work we
call the neuro homogenization based
physical info neural network. So let's
look at how the property is defined.
The motivation this work is
we want to improve the physical inform neural
network. So the classical setting of the physical
environment now, this idea is that you have
an equation this ru equal to Av, the user,
the unknown, you want to predict, right, and
the BU is the boundary condition. And we want
to develop a neural net with that we don't
need to know right the solver by hand. So what
are we using this new rover to help us to make
predictions then we want to using a loss function.
So this loss function include this residual for
satisfy the equation and then the residual satisfy
the boundary condition, then we minimize the whole
thing we want to give us accurate prediction.
In the event the problem with is does not
contain the math scare feature normally,
to give you a pretty good prediction.
However, let's look at one example. In
this you know elliptic equations, there's a
copper here it is an oscillator function. So
this kappa is 0.5 sine two pi x over epsilon
plus to the absolutely the slicer one eight.
So this is what the copper looks like,
okay, if we want to using this highly
automated function into the linear equation,
then the exact solution will be the blue line
and then if you're using the classical pain,
you can give you this red curve right. So you
can say cannot capture the market scale feature.
And also if you look at the arrow, the arrow now
As you know will not converge right. So,
the reason behind it is because we cannot
resolve the funny offset oscillate parameter.
So, therefore, it's motivated to utilize
the harmonic regionalization technique. So,
the idea is that we can say there before solving
or homogenization highly by the scale problem then
we can utilize the asymptotic expansion
right that the you epsilon we can do the
perturbation analysis right so, we can expand
the U epsilon as you zero or other plus epsilon
u one other plus square you to other
and then we'll go on then we can solve
the so called Cell problem right. So, first by
solving this problem we can solve the Chi j here
the Chi Chi is periodic in y then we solve the
homogeneity equation here the AIGA star will
be computed from here it will using the
Chi J solid from the sale per hour. So,
by doing that it can aggravate
the problem of the classical pain.
So, here's the basic idea. So, one of Sol step one
solve the same problem using the
effects coming from neural network
then, when you evaluate the homogenized
coefficients that may solve the
homogeneous equation using pain
to dealing with the periodic problem, so, we
use the so called over sampling techniques,
so, we sample beyond the computational domain
where two or more points so, that we match the
here assuming this is a boundary right we sample
on both sides. So, that was the yellow matches
the blue so, that ensures the periodic relations
okay. So, want to ensure the periodic mapping here
so, suddenly this blue here we're matching
this blue here this this yellow matches
yellow okay. So, what does it mean sure
the periodicity there. So, therefore,
our loss function will contain three part the loss
function in the equation uses your the boundary
condition residual and also the over sampling
to satisfy the periodic boundary condition.
So, here is an example of the
2d elliptic equations. So,
we're using the same setting Yeah, we
know the classical penguin our than if
we using our neuromodulation technique, which
is such a highly isolated permeability field,
we can predict the reference
Roshan very accurately.
So, here basically one demonstrated the arrow
analysis where I want to show you the arrow
for the sale problem, you know, for the Kiowa and
the kartu and also the difference between with and
the result of assembly. So, if so, this blue line
is without over sampling this red line is a waste
over sampling So, we can service our sampling
while you know further improve the accuracy
so, here is also the arrow for these
two D lip their problems right So,
this basically we can show
the arrow is pretty good.
So, here's arrow functions right. So,
we also did some like transfer learning
want to transfer the train the result to
initialize the pain, but the problem is,
we still not be able to predict the original
multiscalar problem I see in the reason is because
these locks function on to loss
function another close enough.
So, currently we're working
on modified the P loss, so,
that be able to eventually predicted
the microscope Gnosis problem.
So, the contrast some conclusion,
so, we basically developed this
neuro homogenization based pin to solve
the multi scale problem. And also we will
propose these our sampling strategy to
solve the periodic boundary condition.
So, the third point I want to talk about is the
interpretable AI for data driven
incentive recovery besides nd.
So, the question we want to ask ourselves
is can we use in the data to discover the
physical law and eventually it can enable data
driven science discovery automatically. So,
along this line, I have developed a series
paper. So, this work is the robust data driven
discovery with aerobars publisher to pursue
law society. And then this work we develop
a Gaussian processes of active learning so that it
can do these active learning for
physical discovery and this is a
Another paper dealing with the large noisy data.
So in particular, today I will talk
about Alzheimer's disease prediction.
So this paper published as nature
digital medicine. So in particular,
we are looking at the essence of MIT this
predictions. On the right hand side, you can see
there's a excess of time, why
is about a biomarker. So if
the biomarker is below this gray
box, that means normal. And it's
beyond the means of normal. So one that
predicted the patient to progression
over time. Right. So that's the goal we want
to predict. So the idea is we're using large
data sets, so called any biomarker data
set. So there's four different biomarker,
we want to using them to develop a model.
So the first thing, so this is a
framework that we try to develop.
So first of all, we basically
try to initialize all the model,
then we can talk to a sigma function and try to
do remove some noise in the data
that went to the spouse learning
to learn also called a causal model. So this
causal model will will contain the very few terms,
then we evaluate the population parameter using
the database so that we can get a population
data and population models. So this model
was satisfy the population of the patient.
But we want to eventually develop a personalized
model. So that's why we do a sensitivity analysis
to get the precise parameter using the
particular patient data, then we can
develop this precise model, eventually, we can
utilize it utilize it to personalize prediction.
So here just a demonstration, are we using
a particular patient so we can fit the model
and then using the particular patient data
can come up with the only model. So you can
see this is a four different variables are
the biomarkers, so we can predict these four
different biomarkers, and then progression over
time, right, we can study the critical points
on the right hand side the equilibrium, so we can
do another a lot of analysis based on this model.
So therefore, this kind of model is interpretable.
Right? We can learn a lot of things from there.
And also, this is a results predictions,
right? So we can predict, you know,
the patient model prediction using
this model, comparison the data.
So the next step I work I'm going to
talk about from the application back
to the neural network. So when talk
about this, fasten your architecture
design with quantify the uncertainty. So in
particular, so the question want to ask is,
can we develop a fast and small and accurate deep
neural network with better interoperability and
the last minute under computational resource,
while the goal is to enable fast interoperable,
nonlinear data driven scientific discovery?
So we have a series of paper to try to
achieve this goal. So So first, I want to
talk about the patient's past learning.
We have developed with pre K teachers
credit grading Markov Chain Monte Carlo.
The first I want to talk about the motivation.
Just a little challenge, a socialist
deep neural network prize. Firstly,
it did require heavy memory computational power,
and the costs of overfitting. And also the cost
function is difficult to optimize. And go to a
local minima is hard to pretend. So therefore,
our objective is to do so personally, and
Bayesian approach, and the computer the
posterior exploitation and the Inkscape, shallow
local optimum. So this is our objective. And to
do that, we have some notations. So the entire
data will use the capital B. Right? So there's
the model parameter, we're using beta and the log
posterior density using out the true gradient,
right, we're using gradient L. And if the
mini batch we use including error tilde.
So the key components, right, do we have a
series of key components as we're using sparse
landing pages approach, empirical Bayesian
method, and the adaptive Stochastic Gradient
launch one dynamic? And we asked about
some preconditioner. And we incorporated
the stochastic approximation and the pooling
strategy. So this is the tool we use trying
to achieve our goal. So first, let's look
at the swagger end set. So, as we all know,
so grins is very powerful, right? You
can find it the map for model parameter
But the problem is the cannot capture
the parameter uncertainty. So potential
overfitting So, therefore, we introducing
the so called launch one dynamic and the
story of the long awaited London dynamic.
So, we using the launch event in fusion with
a stage distribution, right, satisfy
us look at the differential equation
based on that, so, we there's
some advantage also always
stuck with the lodgement dynamic. First it's a
sample we can sample in the posterior to get the
model uncertainty and also we can compute
the posterior expectation. So, therefore,
give us a more robust result also it can escape a
local optimum aims to achieve better upon estimate
also, we utilize the police strategy to enable
us to obtain sparse deep neural network. So,
we basically can remove some you know, some
neuron that is has a very small magnitude.
So, we also do the precondition that because
we look larger than dynamic, the ideas will
update the parameter with different step size and
adapt to local challenge and the resulting fast
covered. So, the ideas, you know, we can utilize
that to achieve residual network compression. So,
I'm going to show you as this highlighted one is
our method it can achieve if we do 90% of spars
day, right. So, that means we can get at the
state of art, right, you can say it's a 91.68
but if we are a master can achieve you know
better than other state work method. So,
you can see 91.68 accuracy we only using 27k
parameters, right. So, if we compare with the
state of the art right that is using dropout
educate you to 91.48% accuracy using the double
the number of the parameters, this is still
art, so, we can using half of the number of
parameters, but that you better accuracy.
So, this is a demonstration of our method.
So, also we can demonstrate you utilize our
stiletto framework we can do there's a high
dimensional problem, so, that using
our preferred approach is red color,
they can give you the better approach
comparing these other using the preconditioner.
So, also this credit preconditioner
can have as much faster convergence,
so, this red curry is using preconditioner versus
the yellow one does not using the preconditioner.
So, let's look at some multiscale problem,
right. So, we want to you know, develop a
neural network right to be able
to predict the McAfee's flow.
So, to me, because you know, multi
scale final LMS so, we deliver this
upscaling and downscaling framework, so that
we input the permeability field that we do
a convolution pooling and flattening, then we
do the dancing, reshaping and the convolution,
then eventually we have this we using the ties the
cost grid solver, eventually we do a downscaling
right to some reshaping, so, eventually, we can
predict the u and v the velocity field in the
in the fine grid, okay. So,
that's the framework we developed.
So, the advantage of this approach, so, by
comparing the dense layer, you'll now give
us 6 million parameters versus our approach
only that 10% of the parameter whether we can
achieve you know much better accuracy you guys
like 2.13 versus the 1.79 Right. So, as you buy
the compound we can achieve using only 10% off
the parameter packet achieve better accuracy.
So, here basically tried to demonstrate
to you the learning curve right using our
preconditioner work and it can choose much faster
convergence. And also here I want to demonstrate
to you about the multi scale you know using
our proposal framework and capture right so,
this is a certitude admission problem. So on
the left is a show in the middle is our work
on the right using the result pre preconditioner.
So you can see personally who dimension right our
master can get a very close to the document
to the to the visa preconditioner is hard to
capture before they include the increases the
complexity we using 64 dimension problem. So
You can see our method still can
capture, but without per unit cannot.
So, we improve this dimension to 128. So, you can
say this our method compared to the ground truth.
And if you look at it, this will be lockpick
preconditioner, you totally become white noise.
So, in summary, so we basically introduce
a method that can do a stochastic gradient
and Markov Chain Monte Carlo, it can
capture this sparse your network. Also,
it can provide us sparse learning vis s&p
can provide us the arrow bar. And also it
can shift the state of the art compression
and outperforming the existing measure.
The following type of talk I'm going to talk
about, you know, very common issue in deep
learning is how to find the global minimum.
Okay, that's obviously a problem because it's
a non convex problem. The reason is, because
it's also landscape, it's a very complicated,
so it's like roughly like a mountain valley. So
how to find the global minimum is very tricky. So
let's look at, you know, videos. So how to
gradient descent fail. So you can say this
started the gradient descent, taking
a stop here, right? So because here,
there's a local minimum, right, the gradient
descent will not be able to escaped, however,
the global insert here, the green area,
okay, so that's making it difficult.
So that's the motivation. My last part is trying
to develop a scalable training of
large scale deep neural network.
So the question is, how can we design efficient
you know, optimization or sampling algorithm
to be able to train a large scale on your
network. And also, the goal is to enable
fast training of a large scale TPU network. So
along this line, we developed a series of paper.
So let's first look at how we do that.
Our tool is to work I'm going to introducing
a series of tool the first year I will talk
about these two using the stochastic
gradient Monte Carlo. Let's look at
what it is to cut the large one down we can do
so assume the global minimum is in the middle.
I tried to do the sample a large one dynamic I
want to say whether I have a nine offer local
no minimum here I want to see whether I can
foster converging to the global ones. Okay,
so here's the video to do that. So here
business showed the number integration,
so you can see the sampling, right? It can Okay,
I'm in the first local minimum is taking samples,
it took it a while to jump to the second one
is still gonna take a while theoretically
is to get on your dynamic wall achieve the global
minimum, but they're gonna take a long time
because they're used to traveling the second one
right, you can take almost a million sample,
right? You still traveling the second
Okay, so can say it's a very
take a lot of times to be able to achieve
the goal of all converges. So therefore,
it motivates to do up in SoCal replicate
change Markov Chain Monte Carlo.
But if we blindly using this technique,
we're going to run into some trouble. So,
therefore, we do have a new method called the
replica chain SGL D. So in this work, right,
so we have to chain Why is the low temperature
there the high temperature, the tower means
the you know, this is the high temperature is
low temperature, so we have two temperatures,
so we run to Markov chain. And then we want to
swamp this the, this rate with a probability
to do the two particles map. So basically, it's
a jumper process, including this macro process.
So the basic idea is that we have two chains,
right? So one, you can think about we have
you know, a red team and Blue Team.
This read him gonna take the helicopter,
go around the valley find it the you know,
the local minima, once he defined it is a
good spot and ask another team, this pro team
or riding a bicycle to the exploration. Okay,
so therefore, we have two teams, okay. One is
to the exploration is red team and the other
team doing the exploitation. So that's
ability. So by doing this tutte teams,
hopefully you can give us you know,
finding the global minimum very quickly. In
this tutorial, we're going to extend
the information so this might be okay,
so that's the basic idea of
As the replicas change, so forever,
because our 20 Linoone output on the
mini batch setting. So therefore, if we do the
naive the sampling rate based on the textbook,
we're going to run into a problem, because
it is too large a bias create from the mini
batch. So therefore, we have to do some
bias correction. So this is therefore,
we have to come up with this a
suggested unbiased, SWMP rate. So, this,
this yellow color is the correction term to
correct this biased, so, I'm hearing. So,
this is our original contribution in this part.
By doing that, I want to demonstrate
you the difference compared
to yours to graduate the end versus replicants
change. So, I want to show you this traditional
one versus this, you can say you can see the
difference very quickly, right. So, after fights
are the iteration, we already can capture the
global minimum versus a one minute, you know,
to capture the global, right, so you can say,
also, if you can say there's a very light, dark
color, you know, so this is basically the idea
is we can explore the United States very quickly,
we can visit every local minimum right in very
quickly, so we can visit each part of the valley
compared to you know, the
stock gets larger and dynamic.
So this our contribution in this
work. So here is basically tried
to show you the acceleration, why
the replica exchange, right, so,
the black one is stuck in the liquid, another
one that they make, and then there's the blue
one is replicas change. So this distance showing
the acceleration in the western cheer distance.
So, in summary, so we do have this replica
challenge students a gradient Markov chain.
So we show a potential, you know, exponential
acceleration, the convergence, and then we also
develop or the rest reduction technique,
so that can happen, the further converges.
Okay, so So here, he says, some
reference some to show you. Okay,
so there's a paper that we have published.
So, finally, I want to leave some room
for all the discussion. So I want to end
my talk by co founder of the winner, because
I the worker in the clearest possible ways
with physics and engineer, so I knew that our
data, and they were very precise. Thank you.
Thanks for the wonderful talk, Professor Lin.
So let's start our q&a session.
I know we don't have any questions yet,
but if the audience have a question,
please feel free to unmute yourself.
Okay, as we give the audience a moment together,
they're forced to jump in and we
have a question to kick things off,
but please bear with me if this seems like
straightforward, maybe I can ask some very basic
fundamental question about the pie and and
for the multiscale problems first. So, so,
like the last one changes,
you include the PDE loss,
the boundary loss and the offer sampling.
So, are there any study or any tricks on
how the ways should be adjust and how
they affect the solution accuracy of all
you mean from the binary condition
or from the solution from the
so there are three ways parameters like
w one, w two and W three in in Lausanne,
so how do you like pick them to
to make sure the solution you
compute is like accurate?
Okay, so yeah, this is what the so basically, we
have in front of each law, so we have omega one,
omega two omega three. So we assumed omega one
plus omega two plus omega three equal to one,
right? We're gonna kill these three omega.
So that gives us the minimum loss.
Okay, I see. Yeah.
So
maybe I can ask a question about, I mean,
the timer. This is so I wonder. I mean,
it's a general question, but I wonder how
we can tell if the patient data set that
you use is a good representative of the different
demographics in the whole population. In practice,
do you identify or mitigate any sampling
bias in this personalized predictions?
Okay, yeah, I think that's a good question, right.
First of all, this data set is
already you know, the biggest data set
So we have, okay, so that's a given by my
collaborator from Duke, like doctors. So the
answer so Mike is so my co author. Okay, so yeah,
I understand your question is very good question.
Right? The population where the cover, right. So,
so that's why motivators to hyper personalized
treatment, right. So of course, if you know this
person is belong to, you know, in my dataset
does not contains, right, that particular group
right, then yeah, I agree we sue them. Yeah, this
one we might not be able to give you the accurate
prediction. Yeah, I agree with you. Yep. See?
Maybe I asked one more about
the COVID-19. Study. So. So you build
a data driven models for minimizing the
observed data? But like, how do you monitor
or maintain its performance in the real life,
real time deployment? To the like, once you
trend the data? Is it like static? Or do
you will use some kind of like, on that adaptive
method or on my learning techniques to like,
calibrate your models? Yeah, that's a very
good question. Yeah. So. So basically,
it's depends on so we basically every time you
have new data come in, right? So we can update
the model. Right? So there's many ways to do that.
So you can just calibrate the model parameter,
because my mother will not raise
it is a time dependent functions,
right? So you basically updated the model
parameter, right, by minimize the loss
function. Right? So that's one way where you ask
him to Beijing way, right, can do that? Yeah.
So do you see like, significant change of
these parameters when like the whole pandemic
periods goes over? For example, if we try and
translate from one variant outlet to the next
never in the beta and delta? So do you see, like,
significant changes in these parameters? Yeah,
I think that the parameter change depends on
several things. Right. One depends on the policy,
right? Depends on the government, which kind
of control policy you can do you want to do
the isolation, right? Stay the whole older then
will be different compared to like an indoor
dining reopening. Right. It's one. Also I think
it's different from country to country. Right.
Yeah. So it's also depends on if you want to use
in COVID-19 model to predict to other disease,
right, it will be a different chip. Right.
So I think depends a lot of things. Also,
it has a variance, right? Because
the Omicron right, will be different
compared to the original. Right? So it's very
complicated. Yeah. I see. I saw in the chat.
That's a question. Yeah. Yeah. SGD so yeah,
Kunshan will ask in the replica exchange Sal
the algorithm How is it decided when to
call the Explorer versus the exploiter?
Yeah, so so that it goes through. So with
this around the two chain parallel, okay,
so we all the things that we do the information
exchange, so we always run to, we always run
these two things together to save time, right? So
we always have to to basically right, this is to
team going to call each other if they have some
discovery, okay? So they exchange information.
So that's why you saw the survival rate right. So
so they can switch locations, right? Think about
that I value them by having nine different local
minima, right? So this team will call each other
say it here, I find good, the one that come to
check then the other team will come over. Okay.
Okay.
Thanks for the other awesome
answers for the questions. So,
there is once more if there are any
more questions from the audience.
And if there are no more questions,
let's thank Professor Linda again for
sharing his excellent research with
us. Yes, thank you for your time.